they say on the news there is no us
soldier in afghanistan that if i'm here
and i'll help as long as it takes
i came here to get my own family out i
couldn't do so but
i've helped plenty of other people
and it feels good getting them out
saving them from the taliban it feels
good but i've gotten out several
minorities uh catholics christians
uh zara minorities and other individuals
and it's upwards of 30 individuals that
have
helped uh get out
to pakistan i came to the u.s just a few
days before 9 11. didn't have anything
i still wore afghan clothes and a turban
i went to high school finished high
school and then i came across a
recruiter and i joined the us army but
right now i am in islamabad in pakistan
and i came about a month ago and i went
to afghanistan but not the official
crossing i came i got went in and out
several times oftentimes uh bringing
more people in uh again those that have
s ivs those that have handlers in
islamabad or peshawar waiting for them
that just need help getting in because
of that close order i've come across
many different groups here i came across
a family of 10 afghan christians
who needed to be moved
and we helped most them
and
we're hoping we've heard that uh they
have already made it out you guys just
went to visit my family helped my mom
and dad i greatly appreciate that man
i just want to thank you you're doing a
risky job but still
you're the man bro there was a a
catholic husband and wife
that needed help to get to pakistan and
they were in danger because of their
religion they have converted it to
catholics catholicism recently everyone
in their neighborhood knew about it
almost and they saw snitching on them
this case reached me i agreed to help
them they crossed into pakistan but not
the official crossing
but instead we sought help from the
afghan nomads
and they illegally crossed them in
on my way back from this area i got
caught by the taliban and they lashed me
on my back i told them i was a cigarette
smuggler and that's why i think it was
only seven times
but had they known that i had actually
just helped a catholic family get out it
would have been worse far worse i
started feeling chills spoke to a medic
friend of mine in the us
an army special forces medic and he said
it was probably infected so i took some
tylenol and a few other pills and it got
better i'm not proud of americans
i was taking a note and i'll never
forget that quote i pleaded for help
from the us government
i did not receive any i needed help to
get my family out my journalists needs
out of afghanistan
but it didn't work out i had no choice
but to come here myself
after i learned that there was an ambush
on my family's house once more i still
haven't heard any
anything from our government as far as
any sort of assistance my small family
is currently at a safe house alone by
themselves just a family of six the
taliban have this thing called a photo
album let's call it they have photos of
high-value individuals that they're
looking for we heard that my niece is
one of those individuals there was one
incident where the taliban showed up
outside of the safe house my friends
helped her move
got my family out of there and in the
process my niece got injured chest
trauma bruises and her thumb uh it
looked like it got broken
but i'm not sure
this injured though very bad the injury
healed but the fear from that day is
still there my niece is extremely sick
they're afraid
we've brought five different doctors to
see her
she's giving given
various types of injections and
medication
but she's not getting better she's
depressed she's afraid
she's in really bad shape right now and
on top of that
at this
new place where they're at outside of
cabo they're low on water on food even
the kids have barely anything to eat now
at this point
my friends who are watching her and
protecting her they too or shortened
food whatever they can come up with
they're giving it to my family
even pakistan here is not safe for my
niece she is anti-taliban she has always
spoken out about them thailand's reach
does not stop at the border
they're already in pakistan
you